[Music]
foreign
[Music]
for Thursday December 8th I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
a wsj exclusive we report a potential
deal between Tick Tock and the Biden
Administration has run into delays
that's according to people familiar with
the situation the deal aims to address
National Security concerns that U.S
officials say the app poses because of
its owner the beijing-based tech giant
bite dance officials said those ties
could give China an in to collect data
on U.S users a potential deal has been
in the works for more than a year one
was expected by the end of this year but
now it's run into further delays so
what's the hold up and what would it
mean for tick tock and its users in the
U.S if negotiations drag on
John McKinnon reports on regulatory
issues from Washington and he's with us
now hi John thanks for joining me nice
to be with you let's start with a bit of
backstory how did we get to this point
where the U.S and Tick Tock are
discussing a deal well these discussions
have actually been going on for quite a
while late in the Trump Administration
there was just a growing concern about
the possible security risks posed by
Tick Tock and some people will remember
that the U.S military has at that point
blocked service people from using Tick
Tock and there have been a few other
changes along the way in the
relationship between the U.S and Tick
Tock and so the U.S and Tick Tock
started negotiating over some sort of
deal to sort of ensure that our national
security interests were going to be
protected okay but now they're running
into delays in these conversations so
what are some of the sticking points
there are probably many sticking points
but I would say that the two biggest
ones revolve around how U.S users data
is going to be protected from the
potential prying eyes of the Chinese
government and then the other one has to
do with the algorithm that recommends
videos to users there is concern among
U.S officials that the algorithm could
be manipulated to help an influence
operation that the Chinese government
wanted to engage in in the U.S or spread
misinformation or disinformation along
the lines of what happened in 2016
during the presidential election those
are issues that were raised actually by
the FBI director Christopher Wray in
some testimony that he gave to Congress
a few weeks back so we know that the
government itself has these concerns
about their relationship with Tick Tock
now Tick Tock has always maintained that
it wouldn't share U.S data with
Beijing is still saying that it's
optimistic essentially that some
agreement is going to be reached and
they say that they are expecting a
timely conclusion to their negotiations
with the government and they point out
that they've already actually started
implementing some of the changes that
they're expecting to be in the agreement
such as you know uh Stronger barriers
essentially to protect the U.S users
data I want to talk a bit about the
risks if this drags on too long I mean
are there concerns for both sides if the
negotiations keep getting delayed there
are certainly concerns that this
agreement is going to be difficult to
work out if the U.S security officials
if people at the justice department and
people in the FBI are continuing to
raise objections to the draft agreement
that was worked out earlier this year
there's just concern at least among some
people that Tick Tock its owners and the
Chinese are simply not going to be
willing to go a lot further and so then
you have a situation where the U.S faces
a couple of pretty unpleasant options
basically what are those unpleasant
options well the ultimate unpleasant
option I think politically would be a
ban on Tick Tock and the Trump
Administration threatened to do that
back in 2020 but never managed to pull
it off and you know there's certainly
widespread concern that there would be a
backlash a popular backlash if the
government actually tried to impose some
kind of ban on Tick Tock the other
option which is maybe almost as
unpalatable is for the administration
to do nothing and expose itself to a lot
of criticism especially from republicans
in Congress that they're not doing
enough or not doing anything really to
try to protect the U.S from the risks
that are seen with Tick Tock what's the
role of the Chinese government in these
negotiations I mean does it have one the
Chinese government has not had a lot to
say about these negotiations during the
Trump Administration they were pretty
clearly concerned about the possibility
that the U.S or its Representatives
would gain access to the algorithm that
Tick Tock uses which is based on an
algorithm that they developed for China
the Chinese government essentially said
none of these algorithms that are the
intellectual property of Chinese
companies can be exported I would say
that's the big signal they've sent that
they really want this to remain
essentially a Chinese Enterprise
and they haven't really had a lot to say
lately about the National Security
agreement negotiations but I will say
that Tick Tock I think rightly so is
concerned that if these negotiations go
too far in
reducing the influence of Chinese owners
and the Chinese government than the
Chinese government might ultimately
reject the deal all right that's a
reporter John McKinnon John thanks so
much for joining us you're welcome and
that's it for today's Tech news briefing
if you want more Tech stories head over
to our website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal thanks for
listening
[Music]
foreign